[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau
numéro du 7-8 loisirs comme chaque jeudi
l'essentiel des informations pour passer
un bon week-end dans les yvelines et
tout de suite le sommaire de cette
semaine après des sélections en novembre
dernier c'est le temps de la finale ce
week-end les sélectionnés du tremplin
des voix se retrouve sur la scène de la
maison de l'environnement de magny les
hameaux
une compétition internationale de tennis
dans les yvelines ce week-end
feugerolles accueille la winter cup une
phase qualificative pour des sportifs de
12 ans et l'agenda complet de vos
sorties au programme une visite intime
un nouveau musée et du cinéma découvrir
l'intimité d'un hôtel particulier au
xviiie siècle quatre étudiants de
l'université versailles saint quentin
ont monté un projet immersif au coeur du
musée lambinet une après-midi de visites
et d'ateliers à vivre à versailles on a
proposé donc une après midi autour de
l'intimé au xviiie siècle avec
différents ateliers une médiation en
fait dans les appartements et puis
ensuite on a plusieurs partenariats qui
sont vraiment géniaux notamment avec
l'osmothèque donc le conservatoire de
parfum de versailles et avec lequel on
va travailler qui nous ont fait des
prêts de matériel pour proposer pour
essayer les fragrances d'époque
on aura aussi une harpiste clara
isambert qui vient proposer une
prestation sur une harpe restaurée du
xviiie
qu'on ait des étudiants de l'ue vs qq
qui feront qui sont toutes dans le même
master donc de projets culturels
internationaux et on fait partie de
cette association culture sans frontière
et on monte donc des différents
événements on est quatre on essaye de
faire venir un public varié après en
fait les étudiants c'est pas forcément
le public qui sera le plus fin qui est
le plus habitué à fréquenter le musée
lambinet donc le but aussi c'est de
faire venir des étudiants et présenté
voilà un nouveau format l'événement est
gratuit
après il faut payer le tarif d'entrée au
musée
donc c'est 6 euros et puis en tarif
réduit ses 4 euros donc c'est le 1er
février de 14h à 18h30
14h à 18h pardon à versailles donc au
musée lambinet cinquième édition et
toujours autant de talent ce week-end la
maison de l'environnement accueille le
tremplin des voix le concours de chant
initiée par la voix en scène et on en
parle avec nos invités audrey bourran et
marc olivier picot bonjour à tous les
deux jours donc la roseraie on va
commencer avec vous est l'organisatrice
de ce concours cette année encore il a
fallu faire un choix parce que vous avez
c'est arrivé à 20 finalistes mais c'est
quand même plus de 250 candidats qui ont
tenté leur chance
oui effectivement alors les les
inscriptions au tout début donc qu'on a
eu 250 candidatures et on en a
sélectionné à peu près 140 pour des
auditions trois auditions dont une à la
réunion les talents on va les chercher
loin drainant exactement dans cette
année le truc en plus c'est qu'on a
effectivement fait trois auditions dont
une à la réunion
grâce un de nos partenaires qui nous a
suivis qui nous a suivis là dessus et
est du coup ça a été une super belle
expérience francis a fait monter le
niveau parce que du coup je veux être le
meilleur voilà dans les 20 finalistes
exactement parce que l'année dernière on
en a
qu'une seule audition donc ils les
années d'avant on n'avait pas ça va
devenir plus en plus dur de faire un
choix je pense me 120 candidats mais il
ne concourt pas tous dans la même
catégorie
c'est ça sa jouissance et de donner plus
de chance oui il y a trois catégories
ils ont tous enfin ne sont pas tous au
même niveau on va dire dans leur
parcours artistique et professionnel
donc on a des interprètes de moins de 16
ans donc on va dire les jeunes les
enfants
ensuite dès 17 ans et plus et les
auteurs compositeurs interprètes qui eux
arrivent avec leur univers voilà donc
c'est important pour nous de les
différencier
on parle beaucoup la de ceux qui seront
sur scène mais marc ollivier en plus le
public va être mis à contribution
c'est une soirée interactive déjà
pourquoi avoir choisi de mettre en avant
l'interactivité du public bah il fallait
un gagnant notre automatiquement on
voulait on voulait faire participer le
public
et justement l'idée c'était d'avoir un
truc enfin quelque chose d'un peu
innovant donc aujourd'hui tout le monde
a un téléphone portable vers un
smartphone ou une tablette est donc
l'idée c'était d'utiliser les téléphones
pour faire voter les gens et donc voilà
qu'on soit dans la salle
c'est ce qu'on faisait jusqu'à présent
et maintenant comment les diffuser sur
youtube ou sur donc tv 78 samedi on va
pouvoir voter sur internet
alors comment ça va se passer va faire
télécharger une application c'est par un
site internet enregistre à twente en
fait c'est une page web donc en fait
quand on vient dans la salle on se
connecte sur un réseau wifi et on se
connecte sur suran sur un site web et
sur internet c'est juste un lien sur la
page d'accueil du tremplin des voix
points comme et on accède à la page et
donc c'est interactif c'est vraiment
c'est à dire que ouverture des votes
clôture des votes
il faut vraiment être là au moment de
candidats passent oui on vient pas comme
dans les télé crochets à la télé ça sera
un tapez 2 voilà ça et c'est gratuit
pour le coût du sms à envoyer
et en plus si je me trompe on note pas
pour le candidat qu'on veut voir gagner
on met des petites notes c'est ça c'est
ça en fait pour chaque candidat on donne
une note sur quatre critères différents
il ya les enseignants
de technique vocale voilà on essaye que
le candidat repartent un petit peu avec
des idées pour s'améliorer
donc que soit le jury parce qu'il ya un
jury de professionnels aussi le public
en fait on donne des notes sur des
critères différents et donc ce jury
justement on va en parler c'est un
concours donc les candidats cherchent
aussi à être jaugé oui et c'est des
professionnels qui sont dans de jolis
oui c'est des professionnels ou des
artistes du milieu musical qui du coup
un regard un petit peu aiguisé on va
dire sur sur la prestation des candidats
donc voilà mais ils sont quand même ego
par rapport au public sur la partie on
va dire vote puisqu'il vote exactement
de la même manière au même niveau où il
ya un pourcentage pour le alors yade au
prix il ya le prix du jury et le prix du
public
donc ils votent de la même manière sauf
que le prix du jury c'est toutes
catégories confondues le prix du public
de sa catégorie faux confondues et le
prix du jury
votre par catégorie par catégorie
exactement voilà on a tout dit le public
ne reste il faut qu'il soit là faut
qu'il soit présent merci à tous les
événements en vrai parce que c'est un
vrai spectacle sur un concert live des
choristes cette année en plus voilà
juste un tremplin
moi je crois qu'on n'a rien d'autre à
rajouter on va juste rappeler les
informations pas pratique c'est le
samedi 1er février c'est à la maison de
l'environnement à magny les hameaux
merci aux très bons merci marc olivier
py corps on verra vite qui est le
vainqueur
merci beaucoup on reste à magny les
hameaux pour un autre rendez vous c'est
ce samedi aussi mais c'est la matinée
c'est à 11h15 les élèves et professeurs
de l'école de musique illustre grâce à
leurs instruments une bande dessinée et
cette découverte est à faire au pôle
associatif blaise pascal
on retrouve maintenant notre instant
cinéma cette semaine m'a t-il de 2min
aurélie rond se sont rendus à la sortie
des salles de l'ugc skywest pour
recueillir l'avis des spectateurs
regardent
[Musique]
je m'appelle simandou car moi c'est mes
livres ait été privé la mission au
service de la vérité repousser les
limites du savoir
voilà la mission des scientifiques il
était bien j'ai tout aimé ces deux
aventuriers qui partent à la recherche
des yétis pour pouvoir montrer au monde
entier qu'ils existent réellement
et puis je vous raconte pas la fin ce
serait dommage leur commande pour un
public familial c'est très bien fait
peut-être que pour connaître quelqu'un
il faut d'abord les mets
avec ce désir sa mélancolie
j'avoue que je suis encore ému pourquoi
parce que j'avais du livre en fête
donc je trouve que ça reprend tout à
fait les sentiments de la petite famille
en fête tout au long d'une vie
l'histoire d'une fratrie
je trouvais ça très émouvant ok c'est tu
devais employer un mot pour mot
caractérise et qui choisiraient quoi eh
oui
[Musique]
il faut toute une famille a peur
congolaise que quoi voilà donc le père
qu'énorme qui est revient qu on voit
tout le temps d'un film qui est très
sympathique très beaux paysages bon
esprit et bien divertissant
[Musique]
à versailles les lampes classiques sont
à l'honneur la ville organise son
deuxième festival au programme des
lectures des spectacles des concerts ou
encore des conférences tout le programme
est à retrouver sur le site internet
versailles point fr et c'est un rendez
vous plutôt inédit le 4 février prochain
radio sensations vous propose d'assister
une émission de radio en direct ce
nouveau numéro de sensations en scène
accueille les chanteuses d'aujourd'hui
cost et et nantes soit le djsi flex et
l'animateur magloire un aperçu avec des
images de l'émission précédente
[Musique]
elles sont peut-être les professionnels
de demain ce week-end à feucherolles se
se déroule l'épreuve de la winter cup
c'est la fed cup des sportifs de 12 ans
une compétition internationale qui a vu
passer de nombreuses vedettes quatre
phases qualificatives qui regroupe huit
équipes nationales avant d'aller en
angleterre pour la finale et pourquoi ne
pas aller les soutenir
chaque équipe est composée de trois
joueuses et bien sûr d'un capitaine d'un
coach qui accompagne piégeuse la
fédération française nous a proposé de
d'exposer le trophée de la fed cup qui a
été récemment gagné par notre équipe de
france et de manière très très brillante
en australie et c'est ce trophée va être
exposé le dimanche dernier jour de la
compétition
ici au centre de cohabiter les gens
pourront prendre des photos justement
autour de ce trophée
et c'est aussi un bon lien avec
justement cette compétition
[Musique]
des expériences sensorielles pour tous
les âges et tous les publics à paris le
musée de lille vion a ouvert ses portes
au mois de décembre une visite qui va
mettre vos sens à rude épreuve
un sujet de nos confrères de via grand
paris peut-on vraiment compter sur nos
sens entre jeu de miroirs et trompe
l'oeil
les installations de ce musée nous font
perdre nos repères échec notre notion
des formes et des distances des
expériences avant tout ludique mais qui
permettent aussi de comprendre les
mécanismes et les limites de notre
cerveau à chaque exhibition à chaque
illusion vous avez une explication
précise et vous ressortez d'ici avec des
notions précises sur comment
fonctionnent les visions comment
fonctionne votre oeil comment fonctionne
votre cerveau alors manière pas
compliqué mais toujours pour comprendre
le pourquoi des illusions des regards
qui semble suivre nos mouvements des
formes qui échappe à la logique
les créations présentées sont variés
mais tout le monde réagit à sa manière
certains tombent directement dans le
piège alors que d'autres peinent à
comprendre où se trouve l'illusion
l'illusion c'est l'interprétation c'est
comment votre cerveau interprète des
infos qu'il reçoit de nos sens sauf on a
tous un cerveau différent les gens
réagissent différemment avait des gens
qui vont piger tout de suite comment
fonctionne une illusion les arrivées
d'eau qui ont mettre un peu plus de
temps tout est vraiment subjectif et ça
dépend vraiment de 2 comment comment on
perçoit le monde comment on réagit nos
affinités soient littéraires
scientifiques nos appétence et et nos
différents c'est ça qui est intéressant
pour profiter pleinement de l'expérience
il est recommandé de venir équipés d'un
smartphone ou d'appareils photos
beaucoup d'illusions ont été pensés pour
pouvoir se mettre en scène au coeur même
des installations le visiteur participe
à l'illusion d'optique donc il s'inclut
dans l'illusion dans la pièce et tout ça
est fait a fait l'objet de l'étude pour
adapter les pièces au lieu et à la
configuration des lieux au décor tout ça
a fait l'objet de deux calculs précis
justement pour que le visiteur puisse
participer l'illusion une exposition à
découvrir seul entre amis ou en famille
le musée est ouvert tous les jours et
propose également des visites nocturnes
les jeudis vendredis et samedis soirs
c'est la fin de ce cette ut loisirs
merci de nous avoir suivi on se retrouve
jeudi prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]